What if south was north and North was
south just like 780,000 years ago,
the world didn't come to an end then,
but how would it react now that
we rely so heavily on technology?
Would this electromagnetic disruption
kill us all with solar radiation?
Make the planet uninhabitable?
This is what if,
and here's what would happen if Earth's
magnetic poles flipped over night. Wait,
didn't we say had already happened before?
Earth's magnetic field has been
around for at least 4.2 billion years.
It acts as a giant shield to protect
our planet from being burned by cosmic
radiation.
The fields north and south poles used to
switch places every 200,000 to 300,000
years,
but the current polls have been holding
steady for the past 780 millennia.
If the polls suddenly reversed, should
we be ready for a geomagnetic apocalypse?
Spoiler alert,
humanity wouldn't die out,
but the world as we know it would
flipping the polls wouldn't make the
geomagnetic field disappear,
but it would strip away at
least 10% of its current force.
Everything on earth would be exposed
to higher levels of radiation,
but wouldn't we still have the
atmosphere to protect us while we would,
but with a weak magnetic field,
flaming hot particles from the sun would
slam into our ozone layer and puncture
it. Extra ultraviolet radiation would
damage human tissue and cause mutations.
Skin cancer could become
as common as the flu.
Would our technology be in danger?
Absolutely.
Solar particles would rip
through sensitive electronics
of orbital satellites.
The damaging them heavily
for the u s economy alone,
a single big solar storm would cost
as much as $42 billion per day.
Eventually,
all communication systems would fail as
would the electrical grids that rely on
satellite timing systems. These grids
are all tightly connected to each other.
If even one of them was critically
damaged, the others would fail to.
This would cause a domino run
of blackouts around the world.
Blackouts that could last for decades.
Rapid magnetic polar reversal with
throw us back three centuries.
In terms of electronics,
you wouldn't be able to charge
your phone or use your computer.
Even your flush toilet would be useless.
It would quickly get backed up.
Since most sewer systems rely on
electricity to move waste on top of that,
high UV exposure could make some
parts of the planet uninhabitable.
And what about animals with the
polar flip affect them at all?
Some of them for sure. Along with many
other species, migratory birds, turtles,
whales, bees, and salmon use
magneto reception to navigate.
If north turned to south, they'd
be quite confused. However,
since many of these species were
around for the last pole flip,
it's possible they'd figure it out.
The truth is,
the power of our geomagnetic field has
been getting weaker for the last hundred
and 60 years.
Are we moving towards a reversal?
Scientists believe we could be less
than a thousand years away from one.
The polls wouldn't flip overnight,
but as they move,
Earth's magnetic field could
be compromised for centuries.
The cool thing about it all,
you'd be able to see incredible
Auroras at much lower latitudes.
You might choose to go to Tahiti rather
than Iceland to see these epic nighttime
skies.